[Music]
okay ah there you go
sir they're in yes we have it
you should be able to see the chemical
plant architecture which one's bond he's
the um he's the psy is the trident
thingy
give us a layout
right
you're at the edge of a toxic
merry-go-round
the main activity should be towards the
central hub which is directly above you
[Music]
bond any thug can kill
i have to know i can trust you
[Music]
well i understand double those have a
very short life expectancy
you are a kite dancing in a hurricane mr
bond
is this really what you want
always alone
[Music]
we used to be able to get into a room
with the enemy
and now they're just floating in the
ether
when our secret finds its way out it'll
be the death of you
oh my god target enough people
remember the people become the
weapon who is he james
you don't know what this is
james want
license to kill
in love with madeleine swann
i could be speaking to my own reflection
only your skills die with your body
and life is all about leaving something
behind
isn't it
come on bond where the hell are you
[Music]
if we don't do this
there will be nothing left to say
i have to finish
[Music]
[Music]
you